(somber piano music)
(crowd chatters)
- I think that she's
embodied service, sacrifice,
she's been an example of leadership,
and she's been a constant.
(somber piano music)
♪ Long to reign over us ♪
♪ God save the King, Queen ♪
(crowd members applaud)
- I think it's properly
hit us now (giggles)
with us singing the anthem and everything,
we're just like, you can't really
hold the emotions back anymore.
♪ God save the Queen ♪
(crowd members applaud)
(somber piano music)
- Through thick and
thin, Queen Elizabeth II
provided us with the stability
and the strength that we needed.
She was the very spirit of Great Britain,
and that spirit will endure.
(somber piano music)
- We mourn for all of you.
She was a great lady.
We're so delighted we got to meet her.
- Queen Elizabeth II is
the only reigning monarch
most of us have known,
and the only one to ever visit Australia.
- In a complicated world, her steady grace
and resolve brought comfort
and strength to us all.
(somber piano music)